sometimes I go to a place and I tell
stories but occasionally I go somewhere
and find not just stories but a really
good storyteller in the grounds of an ik
castle in the north of England is Anna
Cardin it's not quite as old as the
castle that's been here about 900 years
or so but it is just as impressive
inside is one of the world's largest
wooden tree houses beautiful water
features and also this be slightly less
conventional Anik poison gun
welcome to the poison garden all the
plants in here have the ability to kill
you so you're not have to touch or smell
or stand too close to them
this is Royce honest communis and you
can see it it has very architectural
leaves but the issue with it is that you
can under laboratory environments take
out ricin Bisons the deadliest poison
known to man here we have a tropa
belladonna deadly nightshade a native
plant to the UK these flowers that you
can see here will produce a black grape
like berry four of those berries are
enough to kill a child very toxic indeed
in Italy especially around Venice the
ladies used to squeeze the berries to
get the juice and then use the juice to
put in their eyes to dilate their pupils
about them look more attractive to
gentlemen because it's toxic slowly you
start to lose your vision what you do
for vanity rooted Graviola pnes again a
very common plant that you can actually
buy from garden centers yet it is photo
toxic which means that if you get the
SAP onto your hands then invite sunlight
your skin will start to blister once
that chemical is in your system it will
stay in that system for up to seven
years now we had a senior gardener who
came into the poison garden and happened
to see a weed growing out of this plant
so without putting her gloves on she
took the weed out within an hour she
started to form blisters on her hand and
she ended up the third-degree burns this
plant is called aconite 'm nopales it's
very common and it's often called
monkshood the whole of the plant is very
toxic two years ago there was no head
gardener down and sorry when for she was
working with this plant and he died a
few days later and they put that down
too
toxins from the plant here we have a
very common plant again this is Laurel
used often as hedging the issue with
Laurel is that it will produce cyanide
and in fact Victorians used to use
leaves of these plants cut into popped
in a jam jar with the butterflies that
they'd captured screw on the lid and the
butterfly would die naturally because of
the cyanide poisoning now this plant you
can buy from
garden centers very common pot plant
it's called bruggman sia and the whole
of the plant is toxic it's often called
the angels trumpet it's a hallucinogenic
plant so you can use it in all sorts of
ways and in fact Victorian ladies would
grove the brook Mencia on their tea
tables and then invite the ideas around
for afternoon tea what they would then
do is in the tea pot shake some of the
pollen which is going to the tea and the
ladies would start to loosen their
tongues slightly and talk about all
sorts of nonsense we have a license from
the home office to grow cannabis so we
have it here in a cage obviously it's a
Class C drug we use this plant to start
to introduce to children all about the
harmful effects of drugs
this is henbane it produces very
peculiar flowers that give off a very
pungent scent scent is so strong that
often here we get people collapsing
that's why we've got the bench next to
the walls
mandro gonna or Mandrake as it's
commonly known very popular plant now
because of a Harry Potter phenomena the
whole of the plant is poisonous
historically people used to think that
there was a live little man
underneath the plant because if you dug
the plant up the actual tap brute would
often have two little legs and the kalam
and so people imagined that it was the
devil himself often people so they could
hear the plant screaming as it was
pulled up and so a lot of myth and
legend grew up around the Mandrake the
Duchess of Northumberland is the
inspiration of the whole of this garden
when she became Duchess she had a vision
to create a modern contemporary garden
that would educate visitors so Duchess
then realised children especially don't
want to listen to talks on herb gardens
because they switch off but if you can
tell them the plants are actually
poisonous and have the ability to kill
you then you have the imagination of
that child thank you very much to all
the team at annek garden and Trevor in
particular if your
know more about the gardens all the
castle pull down the description